hi I'm Josh Rauh professor of Finance at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
and I'm very excited to bring you an
online course called stocks and bonds
risks and returns stocks and bonds have
always been a critical part of any
investment portfolio but have you ever
asked why it is that the 20 trillion
dollars of publicly traded stocks in the
US and the 50 trillion dollars of
publicly traded stocks worldwide have
value what is it that people are really
investing in in this course will present
an overview of the main financial
instruments stocks and bonds with an
emphasis on understanding what the
finance fundamentals are behind these
instruments whether you're an individual
investor considering a career in finance
or are just interested in how financial
markets work I invite you to join us as
we explore this interesting topic each
of the larger themes is broken into a
series of shorter video lectures with
exercises that reinforce the concepts
you can watch these videos at anytime
and if you need to revisit a certain
topic you can come back to these videos
whenever you like
I'm also very excited to bring to you as
part of the course a recorded panel
discussion with a Nobel prize-winning
economist and two top practitioners in
the field of asset management by the end
of this class you'll understand how
stocks and bonds are valued you'll know
what trade-offs to make when investing
in these instruments and you'll learn
what you're really getting when you
invest
you